when you think about education this is a
broken system that's it
it's a broken system it's a system that
was constructed over a hundred and and
some odd years ago for a different age
for different societal construct and the
truth is the system needs dismantling
and reconstructing in a whole new way we
know more about the brain and more about
learning now than in the history of all
humankind the problem is the education
system has not caught up with the
science and they're completely
mismatched what do we know we know that
joyful learning is important that means
it's ok to say and dance and have a
joyful moment and laugh in school
because if you do it releases the kind
of endorphins that allow you to release
the stress to learn better ok so you're
learning better so now you're more
engaged you're more engaged you're more
motivated because the curriculum is also
more relevant because it's more diverse
and hint we have more academic
achievements but not just academic
social achievement personal achievement
it has to do with students understanding
who they are and what their worth is and
what the contributions they have to
contribute to society we are ready to
make these changes we are ready to make
the systemic the rigorous hard
challenging changes to education and
what it takes is public weal it's all
within our grasp I would say on a
national level it's too much politics
involved in public education there's too
much money tied